yeah the existence of nuclear weapons
pandemics
all kinds of threats yeah
should uh should kind of um
give us some motivation
i mean civilization could get
um
could die with a bang or a whimper
you know if it's uh
if it dies a demographic collapse then
it's more of a whimper obviously
um but if it's world war three it's more
of a bang but but these are all risks
um i mean it's important to think of
these things and just
you know think of things like
probabilities not certainties um there's
a certain probability that
something bad will happen on earth like
i think most likely the future will be
good um
but there's like let's say for
argument's sake um a one percent chance
per century of
of a civilization ending event like that
was stephen hawking's estimate
um
i think he's he might be right about
that
uh so
then
uh
you know we should basically
think of this like being a multi-planet
species just like taking out insurance
for life itself like life insurance for
life
[Laughter]
so it's turned into infomercial real
quick life insurance for life yes
um and you know we can bring the the
creatures from you know plants and
animals from earth to mars and breathe
life into the planet but um
and and have a second planet with with
life um
that would be great um they can't bring
themselves there you know so if we don't
bring them to mars
then they will just
for sure all die when the sun expands
anyway and then that'll be it
you